Sam Smith
is back on TV again and I'm loath to
play any more Clips involving this
freaking guy but I have to play this
um as an angler myself it just irked me
and so
I can't help but play it here it is
you're a big fan of fishing I do love it
yes I do yeah yeah I'd love to be a fish
fish of them we'll take a fly fisherman
I'd be I'd be any type of fish of them I
think I would like to one day I'd just
like to end my days fishing
I do on the sea and I do it in the legs
I've never done it alone
someone's always taught me fantastic
yeah
Fisher them
that's the kind of thing
like
if I found out
that uh Sam Smith is an angler considers
himself one I would say that as that's a
joke that I would come up with to make
fun of him like oh yeah Fisher then
but he's embraced this is as as as these
people just continue to be to get to a
point where it's just beyond there's no
way to even satirize or mock them
anymore effectively
because it's beyond parody and mockery
so he doesn't he's not saying it as a
joke
he can't be saying it as a joke because
then what would the punch line be the
punch line would be you know the The
non-binary Craze and obviously that's
not the punch line
so this is what how he actually wants to
be referred to
Fisher them
have you ever heard of a data broker
they're the middlemen collecting and
selling all those digital Footprints you
leave online which includes your
browsing history online searches and
location data and they sell it off to a
company that delivers you a really
targeted ad to actually stop people from
monitoring and selling your online
activity need to do what I do and use
expressvpn think about all the times you
use Wi-Fi in a coffee shop hotel or even
a friend's house without expressvpn
every site you visit can be logged by
the Admin of that Network that's still
true even when you're in incognito mode
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it to
a network of secure servers so that your
private online activity stays private
expressvpn works on all of your devices
it's super easy to use the app has one
button you tap it to connect and your
browsing activity is secure stop letting
strangers invade your online privacy
protect yourself at expressvpn.com Matt
Walsh show use my Lincoln expressvpn.com
Matt Walsh show to get three extra
months free that's exp r e s s vpn.com
Matt Walsh show
and I'm sorry I don't I don't buy Sam
Smith as a fisherman or Fisher them
you know uh I don't I don't buy it at
all this guy is not going out fishing I
know he's not maybe he's been out a
couple of times okay I've heard this
from people before I love fishing and
then like you go out fishing with them
and uh you know for them fishing is like
you know just a uh uh it's a spin cast
reel throat it out into the middle of
the of the lake with a bobber on there
it's like you know that that's the kind
of thing that he's he's doing actual
fishing I tell you why I know he's not a
Fisher fisherman um
is because
the what makes fishing enjoyable is that
you know it's like a makes many hobbies
enjoyable it's one of the fundamental
joys of it is that you're you're not
thinking about yourself you are
um focusing and concentrating on
something other than yourself
you know it's it's the craft and the
skill of fishing that's what makes it
fun that's what makes it enjoyable
but we know that a narcissist like that
could never find joy in that because
everything has to come back to him
everything has to be about his own
self-obsessions
so anything that takes him out of that
is going to be very disturbing we
already know that
so I do not accept him in the angler
Community I'm sorry we're a welcoming
Community for the most part but we we do
draw the line somewhere we draw it at
Fisher themes that'll do it for this
portion of the shows move over to the
members block um if you're not a member
yet you become a member and use code
Walsh at checkout for two months free on
all annual plans see over the members
block if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]